will he or won't he President Biden
seems like he can't make up his mind on
2024 the White House keeps telling us
that he quote intends to run but there's
still no date and no location for Joe to
officially announce maybe you should
listen to what Democrats want
only only 37 percent of democrat primary
voters want Biden to seek a second term
but Joe is brushing off any bad polls by
blaming the media
my intention is from it hasn't been from
beginning to run but there's too many
other things they have to finish in the
near term before I start a campaign I
think things are a little out of whack
and I don't blame people for being down
I think it goes well beyond the economy
think about it you make the new I mean
you interview for the news
can you think of anything to turn on the
television guy God that makes me feel
good
almost anything
is in the negative
and as dem's weight with baited breath
on Joe the chorus is growing louder to
kick Kamala off the ticket a former
Obama official floating the idea that
Biden should let Democratic voters pick
his 2024 running mate his way to Hype
voters up on another term all right Dana
how how could you let voters pick the
running mate I mean the president I
thought this was so strange okay so
Kamala Harris cannot buy a break from
her own party every Monday it feels like
we start off by saying that did you see
him yesterday in the New York Times this
liberal commentator said this and they
think that she should be replaced on the
ticket now you have somebody from the
Obama Administration and that's got to
hurt right that Greg Craig is saying
maybe we should crowdsource who the next
vice president will be but that's
actually what the primary is for yeah
and if somebody wants to challenge Joe
Biden and Marianne Williamson is now
throwing her hat the ring they have the
opportunity to do that the other thing
is
look she can't buy a break but she's not
giving herself any chance to get a break
either now she's doing something smart
she's doing a couple things like some
ribbon cuttings at some events that's
perfect for the vice president you are
there in a supporting role that's great
you might offer to go to East Palestine
you know sir if you don't want to go I'm
happy to go Pete Pete's trip was a
disaster let me go I'm more empathetic
let me do something but there's never
like a raise in my hand I want to go and
do something and as for Joe Biden it's
very strange to me the way that they
deal with the polls they dismiss the
polls and say well that's just polling
is broken can't pull anymore we can't
get it done then you have this one and
they'll they don't like the results of
the poll of people saying that they feel
worse off because he's in office and
they say well that's because of the
media that's the media's fault okay then
there's a third one which is if the
polls look good for him then his former
Chief of Staff Ron Clayton can't stop
tweeting it and saying how great it is
so they have a lot of Disconnect on that
you're so sexist what oh female vice
president she should go cut ribbons
you know what Greg she should cut a
ribbon at the southern border because
she opened it up you know great idea all
right speaking of that uh why is
everyone so afraid of Joe Biden I mean
we all hold our breath every time the
guy goes up or down a flight of stairs
we all kind of sit there hoping to
understand what he says when he's kind
of why is no Challenger willing to get
out there and Stir It Up you just fed me
the greatest question here's a quiz so
this is a quote from someone who is
running for president all right uh this
is what the candidate said we've had two
years of pandemic mental health problems
inflation higher than it should be gas
prices high gas prices a war I can't
think of a more uncertain time in
history now who said that was it Marion
Williamson was it Donald Trump someone
running against Biden
he said that he said that on ABC this
week he just gave he just volunteered a
stump speech for his competitors and
then he goes everything is in the
negative right it's like well is that
correlation or causation right sometimes
I get those reversed but I'm pretty sure
it's constation Joe yep all right uh
Jesse when is the last time in American
history that you heard the president's
wife announced before the president did
that he was running again she's certain
but he ain't so certain
or he certainly is but he doesn't know
when who's running the joy
not Joe that's for sure
father times definitely caught up with
them I'm sure he's being blackmailed by
the FBI and he's got the hunter thing
hanging in the balance I mean they just
seized everything from four properties I
you don't think they're just sitting
around saying hey buddy so
listen I love reading the New York Times
and this is a former Obama lawyer former
Clinton lawyer this is about as graceful
as me on ice skates coming in the New
York Times guest essay basically saying
Joe could die in office and no one
trusts Kamala so let's take it to the
convention people yeah this is so bad
but what does that tell you about Joe
Biden the biggest decision he ever made
is picking your vice president so
they're basically saying he blew the
biggest decision he ever made and you
can't trust this guy now him whining
about the media permission to make an
analogy it's like someone complaining
about their private Chef you have a
private Chef dude Cry Me a River the
media serves up anything in the Pres oh
what would you like for breakfast
Hunter's innocent uh how about for lunch
Republicans are racist give me a break
it's our job to complain about the media
and he can change the headlines he can
pop a balloon he could he could give me
a tax cut he could give me a Federal
holiday on every Friday in the summer
that's how to change the news cycle yeah
I would vote for that I would be a
Democrat tomorrow that's right all right
Harold I might miss down you'll be a
Democrat tomorrow I dare you make me
change my name keeps saying watch me
watch me I've got things to do do things
to get dumped before he announced like
what
well I guess we'll we'll have to wait
and see but let's step back he said
those things you were right Greg but
Democrats did well in the midterms
abortion Still Remains a critical issue
and ours still have to go through a
primary so politics is still a choice
and the president's thinking they may
make they may decide on the Republican
side to put some forward who someone
forward who's not acceptable to the
country and if that is the case he still
has a great likelihood to win great
advice for Kamala Harris she should go
to East Palestine all I do is the
president the president president
but I think the focus the focus will
continue to be over the next several
months on the Republican side and the
one I don't I'm not in the business no
no Republican running for presidents
ever asked me for my counsel not even
any Democrats do for that matter but no
Republican has asked me for my advice
I'd say to this if you guys don't get
right on choice and abortion you're
going to lose period interesting okay
there are a lot of pro-life voters out
there Carol I repeat my advice if you
guys don't get right on abortion and
choice you're not gonna you're not gonna
win okay there's no agreement on that
one I want to Brian Kilmeade I want you
to do me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now